ich war so abgelenkt von kießling top
und bodo ramelow nicht so ging aber
jetzt mal wirklich ernsthaft wie oft
wenn es in einer konferenz weil ein
bisschen langweilig wird oder mal so
eine kleine atempause drin ist halten
sie selbst im handy also jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich es ist es geht hier um die mpk
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz da geht
es um leben um tod es geht um
schwerwiegende entscheidungen von denen
alle menschen betroffen sind ich glaube
dass keine pflegerin kein pfleger kein
einzelhändler niemand in thüringen
verständnis hat wenn der
ministerpräsident der eigentlich mit
diskutieren soll der nachdenken soll um
damit am handy
das ist mir fehlen die worte sie merken
es völlig inakzeptabel
mir fehlten sie eben gerade auch schon
aber ich verstehe sie aber ganz konkret
welche konsequenzen muss man daraus
jetzt ableiten
na ja offensichtlich ist herr ramelow
nicht geeignet an solchen konferenzen
teilzunehmen
ich kenne ja auch die anderen
ministerpräsidenten die arbeiten hoch
konzentriert in diesen
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen mit das
geht über viele stunden das ist
anstrengend keine frage der mann dadurch
darum ich habe dafür kein verständnis er
sollte sich jetzt entschuldigen bei die
seinen kolleginnen und kollegen den
ministerpräsidenten dass er dort nicht
aufgepasst hat aber vor allem sollte er
sich bei seiner bevölkerung
entschuldigen denn für sie sitzt er dort
er vertritt das land thüringen die
menschen aus thüringen und hat sich
nicht für deren interessen eingesetzt
hat nichts eingebracht hat am handy rum
gezockt und dann macht er noch schlechte
macho witze insofern das ist alles nicht
zum lachen
du kannst ja so sein wir denken da wird
hoch konzentriert gearbeitet überstunden
und den wahrheit ist das völlig normal
das macht jeder unter dem tisch oder
geht man zwischendurch raus und so
weiter können sie hier sagen das ist auf
keinen fall normal dass es absolut
außergewöhnlich das kommt bei den
anderen ministerpräsidenten nicht vor
also dass man rausgeht und einmal kurz
bei einer zehnstündigen sitzung sich ein
glas wasser holt oder ähnliches das
selbstverständlich aber ich weiß von
keinem anderen dass der irgendwie auf
die idee kommt dort mit dem handy rum zu
spielen
also egal ob armin laschet markus söder
tobias hat michael kretschmer reiner
haselhoff volker bouffier die arbeiten
da wirklich gut vorbereitet über viele
stunden und insofern fehlt glaube ich
allen das verständnis dafür da am handy
rum zu spielen und übrigens das ist das
problem an dem was jetzt klar geworden
ist von herrn ramelow
das schafft doch dieses misstrauen
gegenüber wo sie doch alle das ist irre
auch alle und das ist übrigens der der
der der ganze sprich auch von von ganz
links und ganz rechts die afd benutzt
das nämlich dass bodo ramelow sich
falsch verhält und nicht aufpasst fällt
auf alle die hart arbeiten und
konzentriert sind zurück und das ist
unmöglich
herzig sie forderten ja unter anderem
eine entschuldigung das ist nicht das
einzige was in diesem gespräch er mit
bodo ramelow stattgefunden hat dass er
gesagt hat dass er candy kreis spielt er
hat auch noch was anderes gesagt er hat
nämlich die bundeskanzlerin als
merklichen bezeichnet dafür zumindest
hat er sich entschuldigt das wollen wir
uns hier einmal auf twitter ansehen er
schreibt eine kluge frau hat mir auf
clubhouse sehe gerade schlüssig den
eigentlichen fauxpas meiner art clubhaus
plauderei dargelegt und es hat mich
überzeugt den namen der bundeskanzlerin
zu verniedlichen war ein akt männlicher
ignoranz dafür meine ehrliche bitte um
entschuldigung also dafür entschuldigt
er sich gleichzeitig sagte auch das ist
der eigentliche fauxpas klingt ja so als
sei das andere zuzugeben dass man auf
dem handy daddelt wären eine wichtige
konferenz läuft kein fauxpas
naja ich finde jetzt muss man sagen weil
einige die ganze zeit streifen macho
ramelow er hat sich für diesen macho
hamelow entschuldigt dass andere finde
ich genauso schwerwiegend dass man sich
nicht konzentriert auf wirklich wichtige
beschlüsse thüringen ist mit den zahlen
ganz oben und mit dem niveau
offensichtlich der mitarbeit ganz unten
und das ist auch ein großer skandal aber
wird so gelästert also das vielleicht
noch eine ein kleiner insight von diesem
tweet das eben ja vorher diese plauderei
der stadt fand auf der plattform
clubhouse dazu vielleicht gleich noch
ein bisschen mehr
da wurde eben ganz offen gesprochen
spricht man so hallt über kollegen
selbst über die bundeskanzlerin sagt man
da als ministerpräsidenten bei braucht
es merken das und das gemacht ja ich tue
es nicht
die anderen tun es auch nicht und das
hat nichts übrigens mit clubhouse zu tun
oder nicht klappen aus sondern er hat
tief in seinen denken blicken lassen
nämlich zwei dinge eben wir über andere
spricht wir über frauen spricht wer über
die bundeskanzlerin ganz offensichtlich
und dass er sich gar nicht damit
beschäftigt meine alle ehre für für bild
live ja dass er dann auch noch sagt dass
seine mitarbeiter bild live verfolgen um
mitzubekommen was dort gerade diskutiert
wird er spielt am handy und macht dann
noch witze über andere
das kenne ich von keinem anderen
übrigens über parteigrenzen hinweg und
das ist für thüringen einfach schlimm
ist das etwas was einem rausrutschen
kann wenn man in einer app ist und sagt
das ist jetzt der neueste trend man weiß
es sind viele junge leute dort und man
möchte vielleicht seinem image ein
bisschen auf die sprünge helfen indem
man sagt ach jetzt erzähle ich mal so
einen kleinen schlenker aus den
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen ja er
hat sich er hat sich jetzt für die eine
äußerung entschuldigt aber dass er sich
nicht dass er nicht mitmacht dass er
sich nicht konzentriert dass er nicht
nachdenkt ist dass jetzt die richtige
entscheidung dass er nicht an die
menschen in thüringen denkt die darunter
zu leiden haben unter den
einschränkungen sondern dass er sich am
handy mit computerspielen beschäftigt
das ist doch der skandal nicht dass er
das bei clubhaus gesagt hat oder sonst
irgendwo dass er das tut das ist der
skandal
und dafür sollte er sich bei den
menschen in seinem bundesland
entschuldigen und bei seinen kolleginnen
und kollegen die davon ausgegangen sind
dass er auf pasta abstimmen amtsmüde und
und verantwortlich welche konsequenzen
fordern sie denn jetzt konkret
handlungen
na ja also es wie gerade gesagt es gibt
einen weg dass man noch mehr zeit mit
handyspielen verbringen kann
es ist ein amt niederlegen und wir
machen was mich ärgert ist dass bodo
ramelow vor einigen wochen jahr frank
und frei zugestanden hat der kanzlerin
dass er gehört hat dass er die falsche
strategie eingeschlagen hat ehrlich
gesagt ist wundert dann offensichtlich
auch nicht wenn er in solchen sitzungen
nicht zuhört
von expertenseite oder von der kanzlerin
vorgetragen wird und stattdessen am
handy spielt schlimm ist dass am ende
dann fehl entscheidungen stehen die dazu
führen dass thüringen in vielerlei
belangen einfach schlusslicht ist was
coroner bekämpfung in deutschland angeht
auch beim impfen thüringen nach wie vor
nicht gut aus bei der zahl der zwei
impfungen liegt thüringen im absolut
letzten drittel ziemlich weit hinten am
ende also es wird alles ein sehr
schlechtes licht auf die art und weise
wie bodo ramelow sein amtsverständnis
als ministerpräsident war nimmt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren